on se fait un retour aujourd'hui sur ce
smartphone c'est le Xiaomi c'est le 12 t
pro alors il y a déjà eu la présentation
il y a quelques jours je vous emmenais
avec moi je vous ai montré on a regardé
à c’était cool alors on va couper la
lumière ok Google éteins le bureau voilà
comme ça c'est beaucoup mieux beaucoup
plus clair donc aujourd'hui je donne mon
retour sur ce smartphone Xiaomi 12 t pro
on va regarder s'il est intéressant les
photos tout ça tout ça ce qu'on peut
faire avec et puis n'oubliez pas j'ai
déjà posté une vidéo sur cette tablette
là tablette là qui est super canon
pourquoi parce qu'on est sur une
tablette pas très cher du côté de chez
Xiaomi ça reste de l'argent certes je
suis d'accord avec vous mais qui reste
quand même abordable donc si vous voulez
aller la voir redmi pad la vidéo est
bien évidemment sur ma chaîne youtube on
se concentre aujourd'hui sur le Xiaomi
12 t pro qui est intéressant mais avant
d'en parler un peu plus on y va
générique
[Musique]
le 12 et Pro vient de trouver sa place
très facilement dans la gamme vous savez
il y a le Xiaomi 12 12 Pro et compagnons
en début d'année qui sont déclinés un
peu je suis remise aime bien décliner
j'aime bien les gammes attention j'aime
bien les travailler à fond et arrive en
deuxième partie de l'année la gamme T12
t12t pro de smartphones plutôt cool sur
le papier intéressant ils ont chacun
leur point positifs mais également
quelques petits points négatifs
forcément ils sont pas parfaits mais la
question à se poser c'est est-ce que si
j'ai 799 euros on se parle pas d'une
Bagatelle si j'ai 799 euros est-ce que
je vais sur le Xiaomi 12 tes pros que ça
smartphone qui est intéressant qui tient
la route ou pas ou alors est-ce que je
vais sur le chemin du steak qui a 649 €
en sachant qu'on est sur une version 8 +
256 Go de RAM sur les deux smartphones
donc de la mémoire on a donc du stockage
donc de quoi faire alors premier retour
et je vais vous le faire je vous dis
c'est sur le design moi ce smartphone je
trouve très sympa et élégant on est dans
ce que fait Xiaomi cette année avec ce
petit module photo qui est très élégant
très sympa ça me va bien avec les petits
détails mais c'est travailler au laser
ça voyez on sent un peu sous le doigt
c'est très joli après il y a pas de gros
changement par rapport au Xiaomi 12
alors vous me direz on est sur une
déclinaison c'est normal pour autant
lorsque je viens de mettre 700 euros sur
un smartphone j'ai peut-être envie
d'abord un truc un petit peu plus pas
exotique mais un petit peu différent ici
c'est pas le cas néanmoins la recette
marche la recette fonctionne on la
connaît par contre ce que je peux bien
vous dire c'est l'écran alors je trouve
que l'écran ici bonne qualité bien
calibré très agréable en plus de ça
garder là je voulais pousser à fond
alors ici tout qui a pas de Démas de
lumière il y a des lumières qui vient de
là bien évidemment mais il est quelque
chose comme 18h regardez c'est marqué la
18h23 donc fatalement et bien on manque
un peu de lumière on voit bien en plein
jour je suis allé me balader j'ai fait
des photos j'ai fait plein de trucs avec
et je trouve que ça fonctionne bien donc
après vous pouvez venir directement ici
dans les paramètres dans écran et venir
choisir le schéma de couleur soit
intense comme j'ai mis moi par défaut
soit en saturé à vous de voir si vous
voulez dire saturer un peu plus les
couleurs ici soit en couleur originales
on va mettre un peu plus sur le jaune
c'est moins moins ouf ou alors les
paramètres avancés ce que je veux qu'on
sait quand même c'est de rester ici sur
intense en recommander je trouve que ça
fonctionne très bien donc très bonne
gestion ici de la colorimétrie pareil le
taux d'actualisation qui va se faire
automatiquement soit vous pouvez venir
le personnaliser laisser en 120 Hertz
tout le temps ce qui est le cas tout de
suite ici vous voyez 120 Hz 60 hertz ce
que je vous commande c'est de mettre par
défaut comme ça il va venir switcher
automatiquement de façon intelligente
donc ça c'est plutôt cool et ça
conviendra donc une fois de plus belle
écran de bonne qualité lorsque vous
venez regarder des jeux lorsque vous
voulez venir vous amuser parce que vous
voulez venir à aller sur les réseaux
sociaux vous avez vraiment ce qui
convient ici donc pas de mauvaise
surprise autre truc sur lequel ce
smartphone est très bon c'est le jeu le
gaming parce que vous avez de la
performance derrière après je sais pas
si vous avez l'habitude de promis mes
Xiaomi aime bien montrer les muscles et
avoir des fiches techniques très Robus
c'est très musclé ici ils nous ont mis
ce qu'il y a de mieux en terme de
processeur aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire le
saint dragon 8 plus Jane one qui a
parfaitement bien lorsqu'on vient se
mettre une petite partie d'asphalte hop
là on va se mettre quand on va se mettre
ça comme bagnole et bien ici vous avez
de la performance ça cartonne très très
très très dur très très très sec on peut
le dire comme ça mais juste une version
12 Go mais moi je l'ai pas essayé de la
trouve pas on est en ufs 3.1 donc on a
ce qui conviendra parfaitement bien ici
en terme de performance pas de souci pas
de mauvaise surprise ça fonctionne donc
vous pouvez faire tourner tous les jeux
du Play Store ici sans aucun problème
donc si vous cherchez un smartphone pour
gaming si vous cherchez un smartphone
avec de la performance vous allez avoir
un smartphone sans compromis ici donc ça
c'est vraiment très très très cool voilà
et on finit les jeux bravo c'est beau
autre truc et ça je vous l'avais déjà
dit également lors de la présentation
c'est un truc que je trouve vraiment
très très appréciable ici et bien c'est
que vous avez des haut-parleurs stéréo
je trouve qu'ils sont plutôt bien fait
plutôt bien répartis donc une fois de
plus pour tout ce qui va être gaming
pour tout ce qui va être visionnage de
série de films pour aller sur les Tik
Tok pour écouter les vidéos de Monsieur
Gru par hasard et bien vous avez une
recette qui fonctionne une recette qui
est très très mode donc ça c'est plutôt
cool également autre élément qui est si
hyper important vous avez une grosse
batterie de 5000 maheur qui tient le
choc mais au-delà de cette grosse
batterie vous avez surtout inclus un
chargeur de 120 watts qui vous recharge
à 100% en seulement 19 minutes donc vous
voyez que si vous avez joué pendant des
heures et que vous êtes venu taper dans
la batterie vous le prenez vous le
branchez vous le chargez 10 minutes un
quart d'heure même pas vous être parti
pour une journée sans aucun problème
donc ça c'est très très rassurant et
c'est aussi un très gros point fort sur
smartphone maintenant d'un truc un poil
relou c'est qu'ici me white 13 vient
vous installer quelques applications par
défaut je me retrouve avec un tracking
un Maker je me retrouve avec opéra j'ai
plein de petites applications à droite à
gauche et j'ai un fun max ici j'ai quoi
j'ai quelques petits jeux alors après on
peut les virer ce qui nous intéresse pas
on n'est pas obligé d'aller dessus mais
on les a par défaut et moi qui aime bien
arriver avoir une installation vierge et
bien j'aime pas être embêté par ça et je
les ai bon me direz-vous est-ce que
c'est problématique la réponse est non
est-ce que l'expérience logiciel de
mewhite 13 est bonne la réponse est oui
je vous ai déjà présenté je trouve très
très cool c'est très simple c'est clair
c'est les îles ils sont vraiment venus
travailler sur leur expérience logiciel
et du coup ça permet d'avoir un truc qui
est très lisible et on trouve très
facilement ces différents paramètres
donc ça c'est très bien et surtout le
point qui est extrêmement intéressant
ici c'est la partie photo avec ce gros
capteur de 200 mégapixels je vous l'ai
déjà présenté c'est le gros point fort
le capteur 200 mégapixels mais à côté ce
qu'on pourrait reprocher c'est qu'il y a
quasiment 800 euros ils sont venus faire
des choix avec un capteur ultra
grand-angle de 8 mégapixels pourquoi pas
monter on est quand même à 800 balles
ici et nous mettre un capteur de macro
de mégapixels pour moi une fois de plus
ça sert globalement rien donc ici on a
un vrai capteur principal c'est 200
mégapixels on garde le résultat tout de
suite je vous montre quelques photos
par-ci par là que j'ai fait à droite à
gauche notamment ici à Munich lors du
lancement là on commence avec une photo
où on n'a pas le soleil en direct je la
trouve un petit poil ternes là voyez et
dès qu'on a le soleil poussait éclatant
ça marche c'est beau c'est clair c'est
lisible capteur de 200 mégapixel voyez
un peu la différence là on a un ciel qui
paraît effectivement un petit peu blanc
alors que c'est le même moment et là
tout de suite vous voyez donc ça c'est
un petit un petit point de détail à
venir voir ici à côté de ça vous avez un
truc qui est très très bien grand angle
hop là ultra grand temps qui est aussi
très bien dès que vous avez beaucoup de
soleil on peut venir zoomer comme on a
ici un capteur de 200 mégapixels et
qu'on a pas de téléobjectif et bien il
se
peut ramener de bons souvenirs à la
maison ça c'est plutôt cool regardez
capteur principal on est sur ultra grand
angle et après on peut venir zoomer un
petit peu alors je vous ai fait
différentes clichés petites balades
comme ça il a eu un petit peu de mal ici
au niveau des hautes lumières on voit
c'est aussi un peu un peu la limite du
capteur ici mais ça c'est le 8
mégapixels donc on va pas lui en vouloir
vous voyez là principal ça fait le taf
alors on peut faire de la macro
également la macro est-ce que je suis
fan non je ne suis pas fan les fichiers
sont pas oufs plus vous avez un capteur
dédié de deux mégapixels mais pas plus
pas moins que ce que je vous ai dit pour
plein d'autres smartphones alors ici
quelques autres photos et vous allez
voir je vais vous montrer un truc qui
est intéressant dans quelques instants
également quelques petits clichés qui
sont quand même plutôt pas mal hein
vraiment ça sera plutôt bien pour la
caméra de selfie aussi au niveau des
teintes de peau je suis pas très très
fan mais ça c'est le traitement logiciel
qu'on trouve généralement chez Xiaomi au
niveau des caméras de selfie bon je vais
chercher un peu le bazar comme ça on
voit qu'il est un peu plus de mal mais
ce n'est pas normal ça sort quand même
plutôt bien regardez il y a ceux qui
m'intéresse c'est le poids des fichiers
là vous êtes sur les photos normales
c'est du 12 mégapixels vous voyez et on
va regarder quand on arrive là vous
voyez là les photos qui font 500 méga
400 méga 500 méga ça c'est les photos de
macros et on va tout de suite la qualité
est pas dingue capteur de mégapixels qui
sort des photos de macro qui font à
peine 500 mégas donc c'est pas ouf par
contre regardez dès qu'on arrive là on
arrive sur du 55 mégas là ça veut dire
qu'on est effectivement sur une photo
prise en 200 mégapixels donc votre photo
en 200 mégapixels l'intérêt bien c'est
que vous pouvez venir vous zoomer
directement un peu dans l'image on va
venir zoomer par exemple sur le camion
qu'on a ici là vous voyez le camion de
pompier on reste sur une bonne qualité
et c'est très très cool parce que c'est
comme ça qu'il fabrique en fait le zoom
numérique mais si vous voulez vous venir
recadrer certaines choses lorsque vous
êtes comme ça ici et bien vous pouvez
venir le faire donc c'est plutôt cool
vous voyez j'ai mis 87 aussi également
ici 87 mégapixels si je veux venir
zoomer un petit peu au niveau du panneau
je peux donc il y a un moment je vais
être un peu limité mais je peux quand
même venir en faire davantage alors je
vais pas venir autant parce qu'on va
vraiment que l'algorithme vient un peu
compenser et que c'est pas ouf mais on
part quand même de là donc si je vais
venir un peu zoomer par là je peux venir
zoomer un peu par là et sortir des
choses qui sont assez intéressantes
voyez là c'est pareil je peux venir
zoomer un peu dans ma photo pour venir
recadrer si je le souhaite donc ça c'est
assez marrant quand même vous voyez par
exemple ici j'ai deux clichés j'ai un
cliché ici qui fait 55 méga ici j'ai
rien qui fait 16 Mo et c'est la même
chose et c'est là où c'est intéressant
on les ouvre toutes les deux donc là
c'est ma 200 mégapixels je peux venir
zoomer un petit peu ici et je vois super
pas en qualité ici à contrario sur ma
deuxième photo lorsque je viens zoomer
là on va tout de suite que ça vient
davantage lisser on va venir perdre un
peu en détail et ça me paraît normal
donc le truc qui est cool en fait avec
ce capteur de 200 mégapixels c'est que
si vous voulez imprimer vos photos et
bien vous aurez des photos de bonne
qualité si vous voulez venir recadrer
travail vos photos vous pouvez mais si
vous voulez également venir les
retravailler différemment vous avez du
rond donc ça c'est aussi possible donc
en fait ce qu'il faut retenir sur ce
smartphone là c'est que en photo on aura
un truc qui est intéressant sur le
capteur de 200 mégapixels on voit qu'on
a des limites au niveau de la nuit on
voit qu'il a un petit peu de mal c'est
du logiciel donc une mise à jour peut
venir complètement corriger ça donc on
continue à croiser les doigts en
espérant que je suis au mi vienne mettre
à jour cette petite partie là lorsque
vous avez beaucoup de lumière le grand
angle ultra grand-angle font le taf la
macro on oublie mais ça c'est normal
j'aime pas du tout de toute façon je
vais pas être plus convaincu aujourd'hui
que je ne l'était avant la caméra de
selfie bon mieux vous retournez le
smartphone et se prendre comme ça
directement on peut mais c'est pas là où
on aura les meilleurs clichés mais ce
capteur 200 mégapixels je trouve quand
même qu'il est plutôt bien il fera le
taf alors après il y a un autre truc à
savoir ici c'est que on peut venir
filmer en 8k faut-il aujourd'hui venir
filmer en 8k sur un smartphone comme
celui-là très honnêtement j'en suis
absolument pas convaincu là je peux bien
faire de la 8k mais bon voilà je peux
pas venir le vous le recommander
aujourd'hui si vous voulez bien filmer
faites-le sur votre capteur principal
pas plus pas moins alors après c'est un
smartphone qui est très actuel parce
qu'il a du wifi 6 du NFC bien évidemment
il a une double sim ça c'est aussi très
très cool moi je voudrais retenir 4
éléments principaux premièrement ça va
être une très belle dalle bien calibrée
bien maîtrisée deuxième point c'est
beaucoup de performance avec le syndr
dragon 8 plus genean le troisième point
c'est la question de la batterie 5000
milliards période de la recherche 120
watts c'est juste monstrueux et puis 4e
point c'est ce capteur de 200 mégapixels
qui fait le taf même si on voit
qu'aujourd'hui en photo il y a encore
quelques petites imperfections alors
est-ce que je peux venir recommander ce
smartphone de Xiaomi la réponse est oui
ça dépend de vous de vos usages si vous
voulez vraiment 800 euros avoir un
excellent photophone c'est peut-être pas
là qu'il faut venir il fera de bonnes
photos de bons souvenirs mais il y a
aussi quelques limites si par contre
vous voulez un smartphone performant un
smartphone puissant qui se recharge vite
qu'il vous lâchera pas avec une bonne
dalle pour le côté multimédia et bien
c'est une très belle proposition que
vous fait Xiaomi aujourd'hui avec son
Xiaomi 12 t pro alors si vous voulez pas
y mettre autant on peut également aller
sur le Xiaomi 12 T qui a 64 plutôt cool
à vous de voir j'ai pas d’ailleurs vous
est-ce que vous êtes teammidou c'était
pro ou Xiaomi 12T dites le moi en bas
dans les commentaires et puis on se
retrouve très bientôt pour continuer à
parler de smartphone de Xiaomi mais pas
que vous allez voir on en parle bientôt
je vous embrasse prenez soin de vous
ciao bisous Ciao
[Musique]